Pat can show I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in
for him,
David, while he is away. Um, yesterday was
not a good day for Ben Carson, uh, secretary
of Housing and urban development. Uh, take
there. I have two clips. They're both long
clips, but they are definitely worth watching.
The first clip is when, um, Ben Carson did
not know the difference between an reo real
estate owned a property and Oreo as an Oreo
cookies. Take a listening
also like you to get back to me if you don't
mind to explain the disparity in reo rates.
Do you know what an reo is? An Oreo are? No,
not an Oreo and r e o r o real estate. What's
the o stand for? The organization owned real
estate owned. That's what happens when a property
goes to foreclosure. We call it an reo. An
FHA loans have much higher Oreos. That is,
they go to foreclosure rather than to loss
mitigation or to non foreclosure alternatives,
like short sales. Then comparable loans out
the GSES. So I'd like to know why we're having
more foreclosures that end in people losing
their homes with stains to their credit and
disruption to their communities and their
neighborhoods at Fha than we are at the GSES.
Okay. Yep.
I would be extremely happy if you'd like to
have you, uh, work with the people who do
that.
Well, Mr. Carson, that respectfully, that
was my day job before I came to Congress.
So now it's my job to ask you work with the
people,
people at Hud who did that. Oh, okay. Uh,
so at later in the day, um, this congress
woman said over a bought a bag of Oreos. I'm
a container of Oreo cookies to, uh, Ben Carson
and he proudly displayed it in a tweet. Um,
there's so many layers of, um, cell phone
that happened in that tweet, but that's not
what I want to talk about. Listen, I did not
know what an r e o was before this, but I'm
not the secretary of Housing and urban development.
Uh, it's not my job to know those things.
Right. And it's just hilarious. Ben, Ben Carson,
it blows me away. They've been, Carson is
simultaneously smart enough to be a neurosurgeon,
a world renowned neurosurgeon, but, uh, also
a complete moron who should not be in public
service as demonstrated in this. Like he's
been there for going on three years now. And
so he's obviously not doing his job or it
approaching his job with any sense of intellectual
curiosity.
Uh, the same intellectual curiosity that led
him to becoming a neurosurgeon. He's completely,
um, um, well let's just say abdicated his
responsibilities to learn. Uh, so this was
an extremely embarrassing moment. I also want
you to know kind of the smug condescension
with which he speaks to women, um, in this
clip is like, he, he doesn't even really care,
uh, that he's the moron in this exchange,
that he's the idiot in this exchange. He acts
is looking as though he's superior to her.
Well, uh, in this next clip he attempts to
do a, um, uh, Maxine waters and reclaim his
time with represented representative I Anna
Presley, uh, out of, out of Massachusetts.
And it did not go, um, like he thought it
would go take a look at this. Uh, this clip,
it is well documented that health problems
such as lead poisoning, asthma, and injuries
from trips and falls, especially amongst our
senior population, can be linked to substandard
housing conditions combined. These conditions
result in billions a year in healthcare costs.
Many of those most at risk of developing these
conditions reside in public and federally
assisted housing. Yes or no? If les left unaddressed,
do you believe the substandard public housing
conditions pose a risk to tenants, physical,
mental, and emotional health? If left, unaddressed,
yes or no? Can you ask me some questions yourself?
You don't get to dictate what my line of questioning
is reclaiming my time. You're a very smart
man. So you the question, please answer yes
or no. If left unaddressed, which I believe
they are unaddressed because this budget does
not reflect the need. Do you believe the substandard
public housing conditions pose a risk to tenants,
physical, mental, and emotional health? You
already know the answer to that, yes or no.
You know the answer, yes or no? I know the
answer. Do you know the answer yes or no?
Reclaiming my time. You don't get to do that.
Yeah.
Time belongs to the gentle lady. Okay. I'm
sorry. Listen, there's a lot going on here,
but I just noticed honestly on the fly, just
notice that under his breath he said to the
congress, woman, you can reclaim your time
as much as you want. That's so this respectful
and just shows like this guy has a serious
problem with women coming at him with a line
of questioning. All right, with anything for
that matter. I mean, look at how he just look
at his posture and his demeanor. I'm not,
you know, I'm not going to sit here and it's
psycho analyze this guy to pieces, but he's
a jackass. I'm sorry pat, if that, if I can't
say that on radio, just bleep that out for
me. Um, what seriously, you can reclaim your
time as much as you want. And then he tried
to do it and realize that he can't actually
do that.
So they took the argument to Twitter and this
is what Ben Carson said. He said, quote, the
American people deserve better than a yes
or no answer. Hashtag reclaiming my time.
And representative Aiyana Presley. Uh, she
said this in response, she said, quote, you
know what the American people deserve. Secretary
Carson justice. Tell me how tearing apart
immigrant families and subjecting our seniors
and babies to mold infested walls, raw sewage
and crumbling buildings is acceptable. I'll
wait hashtag reclaiming my time now. A lot
of posturing and stuff there, but her question
is poignant, right? These are the questions
that she was asking were important, right?
We have people, we have, we have two things
going on simultaneously. If you juxtapose
the first clip with the second clip, you'll
see that at the same time we have a higher
percentage of real estate owned, um, properties
that have been foreclosed on by um, the effort,
uh, by federal agencies versus, uh, other
agencies.
Then it makes you beg the question like, what's
going on with these federal loans that people
are being foreclosed on at a higher rate simultaneously
you have these housing conditions on the other
side of the ledger, you have these housing
conditions where people are living exposed
to raw sewage crumbling buildings and it's
just, it is unacceptable, right? It is a,
it is a situation and Ben Carson is directly
responsible for the, for, for addressing these
issues. And instead what he's working on,
what he's currently working on is, uh, putting
quote unquote illegal immigrants, are undocumented
workers out of housing, which is going to
leave some 50,000 American citizens, children,
homeless or separated from their parents.
So he's working on executing Donald Trump's
a barbaric immigration policies and to inflict
some type of cruel punishment on anyone who
came to this country in a manner that Trump
doesn't approve of.
Right? That's what he's working on. But he's
neglecting the fact that you have an obscene
amount of foreclosures that are happening
with our government agencies higher than private
agencies and simultaneously people living
in the worst conditions imaginable all underneath
his watch. And what is he interested in? He's
interested in showing his smug condescension
against these women who didn't come to play
yesterday. Yesterday was an overall bad day,
uh, for Secretary Ben Carson.